les gens arrivent et mettent le feu aux choses qui
nous devons arriver ici et tout rejoindre
ici toucher le feu que c'est un crime
homme
[La musique]
c'est dans nos vies aussi bien que les adultes
mais ils mettront du manioc
qui le mettra en premier fera de la farine
ça va griller
à l'époque où il n'y avait pas d'exploitation minière
nous ne vivions pas comme ça nous vivions
calme nous sommes allés en paix nous
vécu dans notre culture, nous ne vivions pas
tellement de
menacé comme nous ne sommes pas menacés
de nos jours
[La musique]
travail qu'il lui a valu et comme ça
chien
[La musique]
que nous sommes ici
Je suis ici pour représenter le Mundurucu
chaque tableau a une signification a
Nom
C'était pour moi, je m'en sers tous les jours
parce qu'elle est ma culture Elle est la
Mon identité
Je n'ai pas besoin d'être avec mon
l'identité que l'homme blanc s'est faite est dans sa poche
Je ceci ici me représente déjà
tout le document est déjà dans mon corps
une percée de
la prospection d'Urucu a commencé et menace
aussi
pas te tuer comme ça physiquement mais
menace menacent principalement
dirigeants qui sont en première ligne
de la carrière Fight donc c'est un
très gros problème à venir
événement
une division à cause de l'or pour
cause de l'exploitation minière
non non
fer à repasser à Patrulha Salvadora
voici à l'intérieur de la terre indigène
il y a une destruction là devant que le
leur ascension et nous verrons s'ils
ils continuent à marcher pourquoi
nous
voir leur style
leur matériel ici pour faire la maison
encore une fois est un signe qu'ils sont
à l'intérieur
j'ai compris
c'est un cabanon
tu ferais mieux de rester avec nous
Va là-bas
prendre une photo très lentement juste une personne
vous devez faire attention à qui ils sont
en train de dormir
[La musique]
non, il n'y avait pas une telle tente.
eux tels que nous les avons vus
travaille toujours, je pense que c'est plus
à l'intérieur maintenant
se mettre en colère, ne devenons-nous pas tristes
aussi parce que les prospecteurs ne
ils respectent le territoire
indigène
Le territoire de nos jours doit être respecté
raison parce que nous voulons préserver notre
territoire sachant que la terre indigène
Mais ils travaillent toujours
ici à l'intérieur
il y avait des gens qui se levaient
travailler pour survivre donner de
manger la famille et ensuite nous serons
filmé quand tu penses que tu ne l'es pas
apparaissant à la télévision, puis les gens arrivent
et met le feu aux choses que nous avons
et c'est là que nous tirons notre pain de chacun
jour d'ici est que nous travaillons pour nous
survivre n'est pas éternel et quand ce n'est pas le cas
la terre indigène est une réserve que vous ne pouvez jamais
travailler
arriver ici, c'est tout rassembler ici pour jouer
feu c'est un crime
chercher chercher à savoir ceci commence ici
De l'embouchure de la gemanchinha à la pharmacie
vous pouvez tirer sa carte, il est tout
le monde sait que c'est pourquoi nous
c'est toujours là qu'on vient inspecter
presque chaque année
C'est donc notre travail de
c'est comme inspecter pour préserver
[La musique]
et ce jour-là
Bon voyage
nous en souffrons
nous obtenons ce sentiment dans le
tête droite et risqué on donne même
dépression à cause de ça, juste à cause de ça
quelle
ma famille mes garçons n'aiment pas
de moi étant plus
faire cette plainte, nous avons peur
me perdre mais je continue quand même
travailler avec ça dénoncer le droit
leur montrant la destruction que le
les gens font
je vais acheter un litre
[La musique]
[Applaudissements]
ils ont ça
impulsion commerciale du mercure dans le
Rivière où le poisson contamine le poisson
Mais je suis crédible
car le mercure ne flotte pas
au-dessus de la Terre lorsqu'elle touche le
l'eau qu'il arrive sur Terre la race de
Eau
le couvre et je ne crois pas le poisson
l'atteindre pour manger
munduruku
[La musique]
très important pour nous, n'est-ce pas
juste parce que l'eau est notre vie
parce qu'elle était censée être la vie de
chacun de nous tous elle a été faite
[La musique]
[Applaudissements]
les enfants Leur vie est heureuse, n'est-ce pas ?
Prenons une douche, allons courir
dans le terreiro que ces blagues
leur
il ne sait rien de ce qui se passe
se passe bien pour que leur vie soit
jouer
nous savons que nous sommes déjà
contaminé
le poisson que nous consommons nous sommes
consommer maintenant tout est contaminé
par Mercure, je sais que je suis
contaminé au mercure
le sondage a déjà été fait ici
tu as du mercure dans le sang
que le gouvernement ne s'occupe pas de Rio et s'il ne le fait pas
passer à l'action
a déclaré l'exploitation minière illégale à Tapajós à
les gens finiront
être éteint ou cela finira-t-il pour de bon
la peur et l'appréhension d'attirer la supervision et
opération pour cette région et achat de
prospecteur du petit producteur sans notice
et ça vient sans note c'est ce qui se passe
parce que le processus de réglementation
dans ce domaine c'est très difficile car
on aime ou on aime pas on n'est pas
bandit ou malhonnête est la même chose que
vous achetez des marchandises sans note
fondamentalement que par exemple vous n'êtes pas
voleur on t'a acheté au supermarché
chez le distributeur une balle de coca-cola
pas de note
[La musique]
oui une bonne partie une bonne partie vient des terres
peuple autochtone C'est une question quelque peu douteuse
pourquoi comme ça
dire que l'exploitation des mines dans le
la zone indigène est légale mais n'importe quelle zone
qu'il est exploité il sera illégal
ce qui est mauvais par exemple vous achetez
d'une zone où il a été exploité sans le
consentement des propriétaires qui n'est pas le cas
ici comme cet effet d'extraction dans les zones
autochtone mais c'est aussi une source de revenus
pour les peuples autochtones eux-mêmes parce que, comme
donc ils obtiennent un pourcentage de la surface
ou quelque chose comme ça, ils vendent même la zone au
hommes d'affaires et prospecteurs
explorer la région
l'exploitation minière aujourd'hui est la force motrice de cette
Région
très sale elle n'était pas comme ça elle était
Vert
L'eau cristalline propre qu'elle est aujourd'hui
très sale
et il y a aussi un peuple munduruko qui va bien
être en faveur parce qu'il ne le connaît pas
c'est sourd, il le donne, il le suit, il ne voit pas ça
les non-autochtones qu'il amène
maladie qu'ils contaminent
mettre fin au peuple c'est mettre fin au
rivière ici
dans le monde eux-mêmes ont changé qui sont les
faveur de l'exploitation minière commencée et arrêtée, puis
se divisera en un peuple et c'est l'un des
l'inquiétude que nous avons beaucoup
génial
c'est une facture qui est pour eux
entrer les légaliser à l'intérieur du terrain
indigène à la mienne Seulement dans ce
Le projet de loi 191 n'est pas seulement minier, c'est
les sociétés hydroélectriques et minières du
territoires est la location de terres est
le bétail est le pétrole extrait le gaz naturel
Donc, c'est un butin qui va être un
génocidaire si ce projet de loi 191 est
d'accord
[La musique]